[Music]
one of my toilets is [ __ ] so I'm gonna
replace it with the the area because you
can just add the nice ass toilet yeah
that's sick can I take a [ __ ] yes yeah
dude you can come over and [ __ ] anytime
you want you never invited me to your
house by the way
dude to the wedding to the house we
didn't talk for like four years
yeah what's up with that that's half you
bro
we were good friends before though we're
best friends
we did yeah and remember the opening bit
was you tripping with a gigantic box of
dildos
we went on we were like did a show
together where we like yeah had a stage
show together maybe what 30 minutes did
you remember that yeah your entrance is
like you sprinting onto the stage with a
gigantic box of dildos that we had to
travel with yeah which is a pain I'm
already having a hard time at TSA
I think that was one of the jokes did I
say that I think so oh damn oh dude I
need to switch up my material
it was funny so Fleshlight sent me that
box of dildos and they also sent me a
[ __ ] ton of flashlights like like 12
different alien ones same yeah
yeah I used I didn't use the alien one
yeah it's crazy yeah
and the aliens pregnant
but I remember is that a bunch of Zach
has like very fratty Hometown friends
from the Bay Area and they all came
through and I had like 12 fleshlights I
was like yo guys like look what I got
and they're all like yo no way I'm gonna
be like super Jazz they all took her
home one of them awesome party favors
yeah one of them in the box I didn't
know it was a flesh Jack
so seduce butthole
and so
Zach's friend God that I'm thinking of
his friend getting all horned up and
then like opening the lid on the thing
and being like
oh well it's kind of small now he's like
I'm already I mean
I'm more like I'm already in the I'm
gonna just do it like
here's the thing we took it out of the
packaging to show like we took it out of
the boxes so you didn't know if it was
like which porn star or alien or
whatever right so he didn't know it was
a dude's butthole and he had we could
use it for like a year
and I was telling Zach I was like dude I
totally forgot we gave your boy a dude's
but like we should probably
we should probably tell him wow that's
really funny yeah damn that's really
funny he knows now and what does he
think I think he's still using
yeah
after hearing it exactly but yeah good
people have flashlight yeah good people
good people I remember they used to like
follow me on Twitter and [ __ ] and they
that was like one of their marketing
tactics they would like send influencers
flashlights and like dildos and [ __ ]
yeah yeah it was cool I was so plugged
up with them they would let me send
dildos to other people you can't say
you're plugged up
with the company yeah
dude at one point holy [ __ ] because I
kept doing the dildo bit on you remember
the dildo [ __ ] I used to do online or
whatever it got to the point where it
was doing so well for them too because
they're reposting it and they're like
hey do you want to make your own dildo
and I was like oh it'd be kind of funny
like fashioned after your penis yeah oh
my God and they walked me through the
process and they're like hey like you're
on flashlight fashioned after your
[ __ ]
you would use it right
and basically they told me the process
and it was like they have to inject a
shot that makes her dick hard like super
hard for eight hours
and then they formed the cast and you
just have to wait with the hard dick for
eight hours like in their Studio
and then you get your own uh dick damn
that's crazy and you didn't do it I
didn't do it because I didn't like the
idea of people owning a dildo of me yeah
I'm like oh
small yeah I feel like you got to be
really confident what you got you gotta
be Johnny since yeah exactly you guys
should get Johnny Sins on the pot
actually that's a great idea and have
him come on as like different roles
he'll be Noel next time
no he comes he goes in and out it's like
he's a pizza boy oh that's funny the
classic damn that's really funny yeah
[ __ ] that would be so funny the plumber
if all of a sudden you hear like a
doorbell
and we're like what the [ __ ] did it's
like somebody somebody order pizza well
I do we have no cash like yeah
[ __ ] pizza sounds good but how can we
repay you
and he just does the Pod he's like
dude I would I would love to see you
guys hang out with Johnny since that'd
be [ __ ] that song He's in L.A no he has
to be he goes on podcasts he does yeah
he's like
he does [ __ ] dude kova did not affect
this man at all he had a job
he was always working yeah I think he
has his own dildo by Fleshlight
probably anyways you should you should
look into um the process for getting one
made I'm not I'm not people would be
disappointed
wait what after my yeah
you know you're packing a little Heat
you'll be packed a little something yeah
you think I got bde yeah let's look up
on Dolly Cody pregnant penis